do you think there's possible
breakthroughs in terms of using fusion
as an energy source or somehow you know
that kind of okay crazy ideas we're out
there ideas but on this podcast that
I've talked to people about aliens and
traveling across the universal if you
want to travel across the universe
you're gonna have to my feeling is that
my feeling is that like a fusion plasma
in its traditional way which was started
in my Sahara in 1953 almost no chances
well I mean they have it they have it
already but the system is so complicated
these tokamaks this big eater become
tokamak is so complicated so difficult
that personally is difficult for me to
believe that it will be like a real
energy generating plant so just being
able to control fusion in order to
leverage it yeah hey just say try
already for how many years about oxygen
that's an interesting point that's what
I'm trying to say that I am almost sure
that at some point hopefully soon it
will be young I'm not so much young but
usually young out-of-the-box thinking
person who say guys take a look I did it
something like cold fusion some tonight
cold fusion you know there's a lot of
guys and girls like that who are called
crazy who've been talking about cold
fusion for decades yeah
so you think you hope that there is a
breakthrough idea that my yes yes I'm
almost sure about that and I can't
explain you simple physics if it's it's
a forty seconds thirty sign it won't
take longer put okay don't try me take a
look take a look what is fusion you take
the etherium three two or the theory of
the cerium you bring them together and
they fuse and you a reason urge that's
it right
the problem is that this is iron this
design they're positively charged and we
have to bring them extremely close and
energy required for that is 10 10 100
million degrees that's what they try to
do now now take a look why we have to
bring them so much close we can bring
them a little bit and it will be
tunneling so they will start tracking it
require more time yes but that's okay
but to do that you have to have three
smaller sizes you have to have dense
matter maybe 30 40 50 times denser than
what we have now how to do that you have
to replace electron by something very
similar to electron but heavier ions if
you do that immediately substance
becomes smaller and you start having
cold normal fusion but like production
and reproduction of this material it's
kind of complicated people there try
what I'm trying to say that somebody
will come up with an interesting
out-of-the-box solution that's what I
believe
well you're right a lot of people
they're a little bit I would say not
professionally just saying oh look I did
it but it but between these people
called between serious scientists
thinking out of the box some several
happen tokamaks yes they work but
there's so much complicated it's very
difficult to keep 100 million degrees
for isn't a long time just very
difficult beautiful unless whatever will
do that Nobel price without the English
you